why did they add a rogue protocol into
Isaac's programming I see this question
come up a lot and I believe the answer
is quite simple history has shown many
times where seemingly good people are
put in positions of power and it goes to
the Head division agents are granted
judicial powers putting them above
everyone else on top of this they're
able to commandeer equipment vehicles
and even Personnel from other agencies
it seems only natural that you want to
put a system in place that was able to
show the agents who are no longer on
Mission while the existence of the Rogue
protocol seems quite straightforward
there is a much larger question around
this how does Isaac determine what
constitutes going rogue there are some
obvious examples like an agent mowing
down civilians but how does it know
what's good and what's bad especially in
scenarios where the right decision can
be a little blurry also what happens
when the one individual the agents
report to changes sides he is
technically still the president so
according to Isaac the division still
report to him shouldn't the division
have had to follow him in order to stay
what Isaac would consider as good except
in the story this didn't happen how
would Isaac have picked this up and then
override its core programming in order
to adjust the perimeters around the road
protocol I have trouble believing that
Isaac will set up to run 100
autonomously there must be someone who
was able to call the shots around what
Isaac can and can't do and if it wasn't
the president who was it